if you want to see my theory about the
secret behind this mysterious machine at
the end of the trailer then stick around
to the end of this video anything I
mentioned in my previous happy deathday
videos won't be in this video so if you
don't know the meaning of these posters
and you want to relive the day that you
watch those videos then check out this
playlist and obviously there will be
spoilers for the first movie in those
videos on the original film I mostly
focused on the decorations on this side
of the room but there were a couple of
notable things to catch my eye on the
other side such as these but I'll come
back to those later in this video first
I want to look at this poster it's the
cover of a book called pulse of power I
haven't read the book myself but here's
a summary i found on google books
destiny is always a choice Tia Stanton
is not an ordinary woman created from
the mystical right she is birthed into a
world where chaos an organization runs
side by side where monster and man live
in unison but rarely with recognition of
each other until the race begins a fight
to gain access to the pool of power
lying beneath her hometown of Greenwich
Connecticut it coincides with her 25th
birthday and her last chance to accept
the full mantle of this supernatural
power there are a lot of parallels
between the protagonist Tia Stanton and
tree gilman from happy deathday they're
both female protagonists with a
supernatural aspect in their respective
stories both have a major test of
character that lands on their birthday
and both have the sole responsibility of
overcoming their circumstances looking
back to that shelf in Carter's dorm room
there's also a mini basketball there's
also a basketball hoop on the back of
their door which can be seen more
clearly in the first film remember
Christopher Landon has been planning the
sequel all along so foreshadowing the
fact that Carter and his roommate Ryan
or basketball fans may be related to the
fact that happy birthday to you has a
scene taking place at their colleges
basketball game and in the basketball
scene we get a bit more info about the
branding of their college team the
babies they're playing a team called the
Tritons and losing pretty badly some of
the team's slogans seen in the stands
include welcome to the cradle the cradle
will rock
baby's gonna deliver which to prevent
any of youth running up on the bush
subreddit is a pun about babies being
newborns and newborns being found in the
delivery room at a hospital then there's
also a banner reading nap time for
Thurman I'm
Thurmond is probably the star player of
the Tritons the one that interests me
the most though is this one that says
baby gang could this be a hints that
there are multiple killers we do see
other shots in the trailer with multiple
baby masks and even instances where
there are other baby masks in the room
seeing the violence happen to show that
there possibly affiliated it's also
interesting because if you remember last
year when I went to the happy deathday
maze at Halloween Horror Nights there
was a room with a bunch of those baby
masked killers something that wasn't
really a scene in the first movie unlike
everything else we saw in that maze in
addition to there possibly being
multiple killers who down the baby mask
it looks like there will also be
suspense about who the actual killer is
and who's just wearing the mask because
they're a fan of the team I spotted Ryan
in the background of the crowd with tree
and Carter after the game he's also
wearing black and it appears this is
shortly before they get chased by a baby
mask with a black hoodie we don't have
enough info for me to really make any
predictions but I'm inclined to add him
to my list of suspects by the way in
this scene in the trailer where tree
offers Ryan advice about being stuck in
the time loop she mentions the following
but hold on she only died 10 times in
happy deathday that means she's already
back in the time loop before this
conversation takes place to make matters
more complicated this isn't the exact
same day she relived before because in
this timeline there's also someone going
after Lori the killer from the first
movie and speaking of that first movie
there are of course a few callbacks like
this knife going through the door during
the kill trees walk of shame a visit to
the hospital ward and this scene with
tree skydiving in her underwear possibly
a reference to the time that tree goes
nude during the first one just a mess
with people because she knows that the
day will reset I'm the skydiving plane
there's a poster briefly seen towards
the front of the aircraft that has the
words like a leaf the quote is a common
cliche and a metaphor for helplessness
but in this case may also be a reference
to a character from the TV show Firefly
whose catchphrase is I am a leaf in the
wind
watch how I soar which has a little bit
of a different meaning in the context of
skydiving obviously but could also be
representative of the themes of happy
deathday since trees have leaves and
tree is the name of the character who's
trying to take control and find the
better version of her life as she says
in the trailer
now I'm living the better version of my
life if you watched my things you missed
in a happy deathday one thing I talked
about was how the street signs used as
decorations throughout the movie were
symbols of the flow of time and how the
one-way signs seen at the end of the
film meant that now that tree has broken
the curse she won't have to go back to
the beginning of that day anymore
time will only flow in one direction in
the trailer we see that sign again this
time through a mirror meaning the only
way for her to go now is backwards in
time in order to solve the puzzle yet
again and break the curse this time it
seems like there's more to it than just
that and it has something to do with
this machine if we quickly a rewind back
to the beginning of the trailer there
are a couple of books on the shelf on
the topics of biochemistry and molecular
cloning and in the trailer after firing
up this machine Ryan can briefly be seen
coming face to face with himself could
this have something to do with the fact
that after each day is reset trees body
is unharmed but our memories of the
previous day are somehow transferred to
the new body will happy deathday to you
finally explain why tree is stuck in the
time loop in the first place
if this trailer is any indication we'll
be learning a lot more about the
logistics of the time travel in this
universe now when I give the dead talk
about happy death day to you I predicted
that the new time loop would take place
on Valentine's Day and the to you was a
reference to those candy hearts we know
this now not to be the case however my
new theory onto you is that as a
reference to the passive aggressive
language tree and her sorority used to
communicate with each other as seen in
the first movie
[Applause]
[Music]
finally there's one pretty creepy thing
you might have missed in the title
animation the fates of the killers mask
is reflected in the knife this video was
sponsored by the C's world of merch
store right now we're having a holiday
sale this month only use code death miss
for 10% off any order if you're
interested in happy deathday or anything
related to horror
make sure you subscribe to seize these
world for new Horrors every week ring
that death Bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive
[Music]